I did I fought a bear I couldn't
remember what color it was but this
happened so fast they were really pissed
about what we said Cody was saying
they're not [__] yeah we were like
making fun of black bears saying they're
like yeah we were saying they're kind of
a little soft I saw Black Bear Once in
Vancouver yeah right give me that same
Vibe yeah
I met one in the wild and it did not
appreciate that yeah it heard what we
said yeah and uh it was pretty traumatic
pretty violent yeah as I was kind of
getting mauled and trying to fight for
my life out there
I got a picture
of the bear yeah but I'm warning you
it's super [__] graphic okay oh
what do you mean that's a that's a scary
what are you talking about got another
picture of one wow oh yeah I'm all of
them yeah I'm out I'm out yeah they got
it yeah cause you know they got a low
center of gravity so they down here
you can't you know I mean